you know I think we forget that
creativity matters everywhere and
creativity thrives in the face of
problems obstacles or chaos and I I love
When leaders get together and they face
a challenge that they may have faced
before and somebody says what if we
tried this this time and I love the the
risk tolerance that goes along with
trying something new in a leadership
context because like any kind of
experimentation any kind of innovation
you know there is a risk doing something
differently because it it may fail and
it may make a new problem
um but it might actually work better so
I don't believe in in blind risk taking
I mean I think you have to consider what
will happen and if it does fail what's
the backup plan but one of the greatest
Joys I've had in being a leader is when
I have faced very difficult problems to
try entirely new ways of solving that
problem that are counterintuitive but
yeah I think mixing it up it makes for
better leaders like experimentation
makes for better anything